welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to
I am hyped Disney have just released the
trailer for episode 9 at Star Wars
Celebration and there's a hell of a lot
to unpack from it throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movie
as well as the nods and Easter eggs from
the teaser that we got this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined for you then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I explain
it so you don't have to do so from the
trailer it's pretty clear that the movie
will focus on the battle between the
first-order led by supreme leader kylo
Ren and the resistance the resistance is
still led by Princess Leia and it's
great to see that Disney have managed to
incorporate the character into the movie
even though Carrie Fisher is no longer
with us the trailer opens with Rey on a
desert planet that maybe jakku or
Tatooine with Luke's voice over stating
that the Jedi have passed on all they
know to her she carries his old blue
lightsaber and looks to be taking Thai
fighters head-on which is just so cool
at the press conference they say that
she had amazing force powers now and
whilst they didn't confirm anything
there were hints that she will be
showcasing new powers that have never
been seen before and this kind of
cements that there's lots of cool action
shot and this really gets you pumped
thin and PO a scene with Rey and
Chewbacca on top of the planet that
seems very vegetative whilst we don't
see them directly on this new planet
apparently we meet two new resistance
characters played by dominic monaghan
and Iommi Aki Aki is playing Jana who is
rumored to be Lando's daughter and this
is pretty much confirmed by the
reappearance of Lando in the trailer
who's shown to be back on board the
Millennium Falcon the trailer ends with
Luke stating that no one is ever really
gone which is when we hear the cackle of
the Empire as we see a segment of the
second Death Star in the scene this is
the area that the Emperor was in when he
died so it could be that he survived The
Return of the Jedi and is now back to
stop the rise of Skywalker who could be
Rey so what's my reaction well as he can
probably get absolutely loved it
I've always been a big fan of the
franchise and I even like the last Jedi
yes I'm one of those I felt like that
film could have been the closing chapter
that this storyline but this one
honestly feels like it's going to knock
it out of the park and give us more than
what we bargained for firstly I'm really
glad to see Carrie Fisher making a
return and I was worried about how they
would handle the character after the
actresses passing but this seems like
the perfect way to do it she's always
been the heart of the series in my eyes
so I love that she's been included in
this final chapter also the dynamic that
they are doing with Lando and his
apparent door are going forward seems to
be great it's good to know that someone
from the original trilogy has had some
offspring that they can be proud of and
seeing Lana back on the Falcon brought a
couple of tears to my eyes to switch
back to JJ Abrams is director here -
it's quite noticeable and they're a
heavy call back such as skips and wall
obviously this entire trailer is
building - the big showdown between Rey
and ran and I wonder if the reveal that
she is his cousin will finally come here
I guess we'll find out in December when
the movie releases but I had a hell of a
lot of fun with this trailer from
beginning to end it's the perfect way to
end a year and I can't wait to see it
deliver in 2019 obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the trailer and if
there's anything I missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
everything we know so far about vendors
and game which will be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who are
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]